bonsoir à tous didier guillaume le vice
président du sénat et le président du
conseil général de la drôme est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir dijon et merci
d'être ici nous sommes donc en direct du
salon de l'agriculture merci d'être avec
nous on a observé d'ailleurs ici l'autre
jour l'arrêterait l'ont marquée par le
président de la république puis par le
premier ministre sur le stand de la
drôme
vous vous revendiquez comme le premier
département bio de france mais ça
n'était sans doute pas là votre seul
sujet des changes avec françois hollande
et puis jean marc ayrault
les sujets agricoles vous êtes le
rapporteur au sénat de la loi d'avenir
pour l'agriculture nous en parlerons
dans un instant avec sandra laffont de
l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire pour ce rendez-vous de
preuves par 3 avec dailymotion et le
cactus du sénat pour la gauche du
gouvernement souvent mise en minorité
tient dernièrement sur les ogm
eh bien on en parlera avec perrine
tarneaud de public sénat d'abord didier
gaillou guillaume votre dernier l'ong
entretient donc avec françois hollande
c'était ici samedi
comment va-t-il malgré l'effondrement de
sa cote de popularité malgré les
difficultés qui l'entourent
non moi je les trouvais très en forme et
d'ailleurs si j'en crois ce que j'ai vu
est ce que j'ai lu les agriculteurs
l'ont trouvé très en forme il un
président qui resté très longtemps au
salon plus de longues heures il a
dialogué avec l'ensemble des
professionnels de l'agriculture avec les
organisations syndicales
on a pu s'apercevoir outre évidemment
qu'il connaissait bien ses dossiers mais
c'est pas là qu'il a trouvé du réconfort
mais bien sûr que si il a trouvé du
réconfort parce que sur les sujets qui
là qu'il a évoqué contrairement à ce que
l'on peut croire le monde agricole n'est
pas forcément hostiles au président de
la république lorsque celui ci va dans
le sens de la transformation de
l'agriculture vers plus de compétitivité
vers plaqueur bord vers moins de normes
c'est ce qui s'est passé je les trouvais
vraiment très enfants très en forme
n'est pas que parler que des questions
agricoles à quoi peut-il s'accrocher
selon vous aujourd'hui pour sortir de
l'ornière
je crois qu'il s'accroche à une vision
qu'il a de la politique
cette vision elle est simple la première
c'est de rassembler le pays rassembler
des françaises et des français autour de
conviction vous me direz moins de 20%
pendant les 69 ans et arrive pas
beaucoup oui mais pourquoi n'y arrive
t'il pas beaucoup parce que tout
simplement
cette crise est dévastatrice et les
mesures qu'il prend pour passer la crise
pour aller de l'avant pour après essayer
de reconquérir et bien sont difficiles
et mal comprise parfois il y à des
incompréhensions parfois même à
l'intérieur de la majorité voire du
gouvernement ah oui discours ne sont pas
toujours aussi clair qu'il pourrait
l'être bref vous avez des regrets la
critique alesi mais j'ai des regrets en
me disant tout simplement une des
critiques
il faut absolument que tous les
responsables politiques qui soutiennent
le gouvernement s'exprime en positif
s'exprime en communiquant positivement
sur les actions du gouvernement et non
pas sur ce qu il pas bon qu'il devrait
aller sur quoi mais ce sur quoi alors eh
bien je vais vous dire par exemple le
pacte de responsabilité qui est vraiment
la nouvelle annonce du président de la
république qui n'est pas un tournant
mais qui est l'affirmation d'une
politique social-démocrate un élan sera
revendiquée revendiqué je pense que la
politique de l'offre
c'est la seule qui peut marcher
aujourd'hui le reste a déjà été c'est
vous le disiez vous à vendre l'intro ce
qui reste quand même un virage enfin
pas par le chef de l'état lors de sa
conférence avec vous le disiez vous
lorsque l'on regarde tous les élus
locaux et les maires des grandes villes
les présidents de conseils généraux
comme je suis quel est notre travail
tous les jours c'est nous appuyer sur
les pme il faut faire la différence
entre les grands patrons du cac 40 qui
sont importants pour notre pays entre
celles et ceux qui te pousse qui se
partage des dividendes
et puis le chef d'entreprise le patron
pme ou de tpe qui lui est au charbon
tous les 500 ans vous vous défendez la
politique de l'offre comment vous dans
votre région vous dire c'est que les
salariés de ces entreprises soutiennent
leurs patrons brave alors vous disent
ils savent que si l'art l'entreprise
marchera ils garderont leur emploi on
dit aujourd'hui l'objectif du chef de
l'état sa nécessité même sa survie set
fédérer autour de ce pacte de
responsabilité didier guillaume alors
vous l'avez bien vu
il est incompris des électeurs de gauche
qui le jugent justement pas du tout de
gauche là parce que il est incompris
parce que peut-être mal expliqué et on
va essayer d'en parler alors tous les
deux ans ou tous simplement parce qu'il
n'est pas encore mise en application de
wasseiges certains se disent que ça va
faire pschitt
oui mais de quoi s'agit-il il ya
toujours des gens qui pensent qu'ils
pensent que ça va faire pschitt ou ça ne
marchera pas moi je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent qu'avec des convictions
fortes c'est pas parce que c'est
impossible qu'on ne doit pas essayer
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit tout
simplement de faire un constat simple
que nous disons depuis fort longtemps
que les entreprises sont plombées dans
leur compétitivité par rapport aux
charges
nos prédécesseurs avaient c'est une
autre politique on a bien vu qu'elle
n'avait pas marché aujourd'hui françois
hollande dit d'ailleurs un peu en écho
aux chefs d'entreprise pas uniquement
aux élèves parce que le medef certains
agitent le chiffon rouge du medef
mais de toutes les façons le medef
s'exprime beaucoup et réaffirme qu'il
n'est pas question de céder sur des
contreparties j'ai d'ailleurs sur
dilemme je crois qu'il est comme ça ce
mardi même dit guillaume
le plus pur national du parti socialiste
vote un texte sur le pacte de
responsabilité où aucune contrepartie
n'est mentionné en termes de création
d'emplois mais je corrige espère bien
quand même que c'est pas le bureau
national du parti socialiste qui va
laisser des contreparties qui devront
avoir lieu après la négociation nous
n'en sommes pas là ah oui c'est vrai
c'est une attitude prudente nous avons
tourné une page
la page de 2012 nous avons tourné la
page de l'autoritarisme de 1 une
personne décide tout tout seul ça issa
change
nous nous pensons que le dialogue social
que le dialogue entre les partenaires
sociaux et le patronat est indispensable
donc aucune mesure ne va être prise
avant que ce dialogue et 20h et à berné
une conclusion et après ce que nous
disons ici que nous assumons totalement
le fait de baisser les charges pour les
entreprises pour leur donner plus de
compétitivité
après faut-il distinguer entre la taille
des entreprises
je j'entendais récemment comme vous le
patron de la poste qui disait que il a
gagné 301 millions de par le cic eux
tant mieux pour la poste est ce que ces
320 millions seraient pas plus utile
pour des pme pour déterrer heures de
troupes sur le terrain je pense qu'il
faut vérifier quand même le mécanisme
est évidemment en place vous espérez
vous combien de création d'emplois vous
avez un chiffre en gérer ces femmes et 6
et 500 milles ça sera parfait déjà
beaucoup parce qu'il ya eu des
sensations ci serait alors d une
estimation qui est officiel que tomber
et qui estime que avec la baisse des
charges patronales sur l'île sur les
plus bas salaires un an créerait dans
notre pays
trois cent mille emplois un maximum
c'est peu oui mais on crée trois cent
mille emplois là encore c'est les mêmes
qui font ces études les mêmes qui
n'avait pas vu venir la crise qui nous
commente la crise passée n'est pas ce
qui va avoir lieu devant 3000 emplois
peut-être mais imaginez trois cent mille
trois cent dix mois imaginez trois cent
mille personnes qui aujourd'hui sont au
chômage alors on emploie ça changera
tous savaient l'engagement du président
de la république à inverser la courbe du
chômage à faire baisser le nombre de
chauvet d'une erreur elle est quasiment
réussi ce n'est pas une erreur il faut
fixer un cap teneur des tables et ward a
réussi à moitié parce que le chômage des
jeunes a baissé
oui mais il avait vu l'amoureux aime
aujourd'hui même aujourd'hui même la
commission à bruxelles qui est assez
sévère
sur la france estime qu' il n'y aura pas
de baisse du chômage dans notre pays
avant deux ans moi ce que je constate
c'est que cette année le chômage il a
moins augmenté que précédemment et que
quand même quoi des jeunes qui se
retrouvent employé par un emplois
d'avenir par les collectivités locales
vous même dans la drôme j'en ai j'en ai
pris sans nous en avons pris 150 et ces
jeunes là que j'ai rencontré
dernièrement avec le ministre du travail
monsieur sapins sont ravis d'avoir un
contrât de travail d'être au smic et
bien inversée la coupe de la courbe du
chômage pour les jeunes c'est quelque
chose de formidable
alors il faut aller plus loin pour
l'ensemble évidemment et là aussi vous
êtes concerné comme président d'une
grande collectivité territoriale le
département de la drôme se sont
les contreparties en termes budgétaires
cette fois aussi vide et guillaume vous
êtes prêt à faire des économies vous
avez la possibilité vous de faire des
économies mais toutes les collectivités
locales font déjà beaucoup décrivent en
faire plus là je pense qu'il ne faut pas
montrer les collectivités locales du
doigt la maison habitée par des gens
publient les collègues les collectivités
locales elles elles investissent donc
elles maintiennent l'emploi sur le
territoire
beaucoup de français d'ailleurs il ya un
peu de schizophrénie quelque part il
faut moins d'impôts et je les comprends
moins de fonctionnaires faut baisser des
déficits par contre quand ça les touche
directement
il faut plus de policiers plus
d'instituteurs plus de monde dans les
récemment la cour des comptes dit il ya
moins de contrôle qui est fait pas
forcément et à moins de contrôle qui
fait parce qu'il ya moins de
fonctionnaires donc je pense que nous
avons besoin pour les collectivités
locales comme pour la fonction publique
de repenser totalement l'organisation de
notre pays
et moi je suis prêt à prendre ma part et
les collectivités les départements
soient mêlées à prendre leur part dans
la clarification
ben vous dans ça vous voulez préserver
les départements quand même j'imagine
mais pourquoi faudrait-il dès supprimés
parce que le débat sur la table certains
élus proposent tient à jean françois
copé le président de l'ump oui mais elle
est supprimée
bien sûr mais jean-françois copé et les
candidats ump aux prochaines élections
cantonales froid qu'ils allaient
expliqué qu'il se présente mais qui
veulent supprimer les départements le
département un double rôle essentiel
celui des solidarités sociales et des
solidarités territoriales et celui-là il
est irremplaçable
par contre si vous me dites il faut
clarifier il faut peut-être pas que les
régions et les débrayages en évitant les
doublons cela se fasse doblo nous
arrange d'accord il ya du travail à
titre havas parler du pacte de
responsabilité on peut également parler
de la loi de transition énergétique
parce que là ce sont deux textes
importants sur lesquels les verts le
disent eux mêmes d'ailleurs il pourrait
y avoir rupture donc séparation est ce
que vous êtes de ceux à gauche qui
disent à propos des verts qu'il s'en
aille ou qu'on les vire
moi je suis de ceux qui disent qu'il
reste et qu'il continue à faire du bon
travail comme le fond pascal canfin et
cécile duflot au gouvernement il ne faut
pas confondre le débat politique globale
qui a pu se passer le week-end dernier
et puis le travail du gouvernement
cécile duflot est une très bonne
ministre
elle a fait voter une loi sur le
logement notamment une loi sur
l'urbanisme
qui passe bien bonne ministre celle
manquée toute solidarité gouvernementale
ne mentent elles ne manquent pas tout
sous des rites et google affaibli et
d'affaiblir le premier ministre avait
dans l'accord avec les verts il avait
deux points d'un accord qui avait été
actée ce sont le nucléaire et l'aéroport
de notre dame des landes dont tac nous
ne sommes pas sur la même position
les verts les verts veulent sortir du
nucléaire ce n'est pas la position des
socialistes les verts ne veulent pas de
cet aéroport
le projet commence alors la toujours
pourquoi vingt ans des milliards
beaucoup je vois bien voulu douarnenez
cécile duflot on va pas faire une
fixation sur elle mais enfin pourquoi
vous lui pardonner elles d'affaiblir le
premier ministre
mais je veux la partager n'ai rien à
pardonner à cécile duflot
moi je pense que les verts en toute leur
place dans cette majorité toute leur
place dans son antre du premier ministre
j'ai sonné les matins mais j'ai dû
rentrer la tête qu'ils vont rester le
plus longtemps possible
le premier ministre a voulu dimanche
soir faire une vérification
oui est ce que les verts europe écologie
les verts condamné les violences ou pas
et mac os la nouvelle porte parole des
verts
les a condamné lançant les écolos les
ans condamnées dont acte il n'y a plus
de sujets il n'y a plus de sujet on dit
que françois hollande train plus les
écologistes à l'extérieur du
gouvernement quelques à l'intérieur
c'est votre cas aussi non jeune clara tu
ne crois port n'a pas à craindre les uns
et les autres
aujourd'hui un contrat de gouvernement
entre le parti radical de gauche
écologie les verts europe ecologie les
verts les socialistes
il faut aller au bout de ce contrat de
gouvernement dans l'intérêt de la france
il ya des points sur lesquels nous ne
sommes pas tout à fait d'accord nous en
discutons là encore nous sommes là pour
la discussion mais évidemment il ne peut
pas y avoir deux positions divergent le
premier ministre a rappelé aujourd'hui
même je crois que le point fort serait
le pacte de responsabilité et c'est là
où nous verrons qui est dans la majorité
gouvernementale et qu'il n'y ait pas
comme ça mais on peut toujours chercher
la petite bête comme on dit chez moi et
aujourd'hui il ya un gouvernement qui
est au boulot
il ya une majorité qui le soutient
essayons de gagner la majorité gagne
c'est pas pour elle ce hacker la france
alors vous dites donc encore le pack de
responsabilité les verts ajoutent
le texte qui va venir cet été sur la
transition énergétique vous êtes dans un
département où il ya une très grande
centrale et anciennes centrales
nucléaires est-ce que vous par exemple
vous êtes partisan de sa prolongation
au-delà des 40 ans oui oui oui je suis
plein cela à leur bord est en décalage
avec n'aurait pas du tout moi je suis
pour l'objectif fixé
le président de la république de passer
notre mix énergétique de 75 % à 50 %
pour la part du nucléaire
eh bien nous allons y arriver cela dit
c'est pas un gouvernement ou une
majorité ou un parti politique de
décider s'ils ferment ou non une
centrale nucléaire
c'est à l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
et moi j'y tiens le la snc le meilleur
gendarme du monde c'est à eux de nous
dire s'il faut fermer fessenheim ou pas
s'il faut fermer une autre centrale où
pendant que après le politique prend ses
responsabilités mais en aucun cas si le
politique se met à dire je vais fermer
ce site fermé cela ça ne tient pas la
route petite question vous ne réclamez
pas un remaniement au non non non
prendre maintenant il y en aura
forcément une rupture mais pas un autre
premier ministre donne en use non manuel
vals non non on pourrait en citer
beaucoup d'autres je suis sûr qu'il y
aurait plein d'autres pour cette
rencontre tenue comme ça vous savez le
remaniement il est dans la dans les
mains du président de l'aje et je suis
sûr que françois hollande fera ça au bon
moment c'est ce n'est pas un remaniement
qui règlent quoi que chacun sait
seulement des tracés sur un drap c'est
sûr alors la visite de francs selon
justement vous l'avez rappelé didier
ohmer s'est plutôt bien passé ici au
salon de l'agriculture
quel est son image dans le monde
agricole sachant que nicolas sarkozy lui
même n'avait pas d'atomes crochus on
peut le dire
plus généralement qu'attend le monde
agricole de la politique aujourd'hui et
bien julien cholin a voulu le savoir ici
même ce matin là le premier ministre est
en visite au salon autour de lui une
foule de micros et de caméras certains
ici et là semble perplexe
ils ont besoin de se rapprocher des
agriculteurs et c'est aussi ici qu'on
peut peut-être faire passer certains
messages
disons le clairement en deux ans
françois hollande n'a pas vraiment
convaincu les attentes elles restent les
mêmes des individus rudiments du métier
à des gens sous contrat donc tributaire
de des aides de la pac de de tout ça on
pourrait déjà vivre de son métier comme
tous les continents goy en fin de
parcours le premier ministre s'adresse
au monde rural
tout au fond un agriculteur en cravate
semble bien attentif
là ils viennent de dire c'est pas une
agriculture retourner vers le passé
c'est une agriculture aux tournées vers
l'avenir
aujourd'hui l'avenir c'est la
modernisation des bâtiments d'élevage
c'est la modernisation des filières
agroalimentaire c'est de la recherche
et c'est là qu'on met le moins de
moyenne et c'est là qu'on met le plus de
normes et c'est là qu'on lève le moins
de formalités administratives les
formalités l'administratif la corvée la
vrai pour beaucoup d'agriculteurs
pourtant françois hollande leur a promis
de simplifier tout ça mais ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'on nous le promet
et qui au fur et à mesure malgré tout
les contraintes sont toujours lors voir
tous les ans on en rajoute on ne fait
que d'accumuler
michael est venu pour présenter l'autre
star du salon sa collègue de travail
la moissonneuse batteuse pas le temps de
croiser le premier ministre de toute
façon il n'attend plus grand chose
trop souvent nous élus se dédouane en
disant on n'est pas responsable c'est
bruxelles
c'est l'europe c'est un peu décevant
l'europe presque un gros mot ici xavier
assiste au concours de la plus belle
rouge laitière l'année dernière c'est
lui qui avait remporté le premier prix
depuis il a mis la clé sous la porte
beaucoup d'éleveurs pas celui qu'on a vu
que le prix du lait mais pas la route r2
ou projettent par rapport aux coûts de
production
à 50 ans il a retrouvé un emploi dans
une coopérative une réalité bien loin
selon lui des discours politiques
on avait voté non et deux oui
aujourd'hui à l'européenne
aujourd'hui c'est la finance qui gros
magot voilà la finance elle qui joue
avec les prix celle là même que françois
hollande avait pourtant promis de mettre
au pas la sandra laffont notre consoeur
de l' agence france presse pour qui les
questions agricoles souvent complexes
n'ont plus de secrets est avec nous ce
soir sans avoir vos questions à didier
guillaume donc vous êtes président du
conseil général de la drôme premier
département bio de france mais les
surfaces bio en france et seulement 4%
alors est ce que c'est le bio qui va
sauver notre agriculture
ah non pas du tout je pense que le bio
correspond à une demande de la société
une demande des consommateurs
lorsque l'on parle agriculture faut
souvent parler toujours par les
alimentations et consommateurs mais le
bio c'est une façon d'être et une façon
de se comporter
je pense que c'est important dans mon
département ces 15 % de la surface qui
est en quête en bio donc c'est beaucoup
plus que quand france ça permet à des
petits agriculteurs et des petites
surfaces de vivre ça permet d'avoir des
revenus et ça permet de répondre à une
demande de nos consommateurs
mais pour nous en sortir dans
l'agriculture française il faut de la
compétitivité
il faut du développement économique il
faut de la recherche d'innovation et il
faut de l'export donc c'est ça la vie
culture ya pas une agriculture
il ya des habitants vous avez votre
choix dans la drôme ah non pas du tout
nous avons alors que ça quand on arrive
au salon les grands panneaux en
impression vous êtes imbattable
j'espère que nous resterons premier
département bio de france mais parce que
nous sommes sur l'air de l' agence
nationale bio et c'est pour ça que nous
tirant sur le fil du bio qui est
important mais au delà dans la drôme au
delà du bio il ya aussi de grandes
entreprises financières ou céréalière il
ya aussi de grandes entreprises
agroalimentaires qui compte donc vous
êtes pour l'agriculture industrielle
vous soutenez cette agriculture là outre
le bio mais évidemment mais attendez
l'agriculture aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
de chance dans ce pays on a une vie
d'une agriculture qui exportent et cette
agriculture permet d'avoir une balance
du commerce extérieur positive oui mais
on a perdu des rangs on est passé de la
5e place 2e place à la cinquième place
suivi derrière l'allemagne derrière les
pays oui c'est vrai c'est terrible on a
quand même des coûts est effectivement
sandra à l'occasion de ce salon que
l'allemagne dépassée en matière
d'exportations une puissance agricole de
france et du monde de rome ces dix
dernières années l'agriculture française
a reculé et il faut que la vie de
l'auteure française reprennent une place
de choix pour qu'elle reprenne une place
de choix
il faut plusieurs choses il faut
commencer par le début le début c'est la
formation
il faut qu'un système de formation
performant encore plus performants se
développe nous avons la chance dans ce
pays l'enseignement agricole est un
joyau l'enseignement agricole permet de
feu de créer des travailleurs à la
sortie de l'enseignement agricole on
trouve un boulot immédiatement ce qui
est pas forcément cas ailleurs ensuite
c'est le pari de la jeunesse et de
l'installation et tout ce que fait
stéphane le foll le ministre de la
culture sous l'autorité du président de
la république c'est le travail et sur
l'installation l'installation des jeunes
si on nous arrivons à faire ça les
choses repartiront et enfin 3 et après
troisièmement il faut absolument de la
recherche de l'innovation du
développement pour concurrencer les
autres pays comme dans tous les secteurs
dans tous les secteurs
sur ces deux sujets il ya deux points la
première chose l'installation est
difficile de plus en plus difficile vous
avez des enfants j'imagine vous leur
conseille aurélien de devenir
agriculteur aujourd'hui belges ont passé
là je vais bien sûr mais bien sûr parce
que c'est difficile mais sauf que depuis
l'année dernière à en relation avec les
jeunes agriculteurs le ministre
stéphane le foll a réussi de mettre en
place un plan d'installation qui fait
que six mille installations l'année
dernière il y en aura autant cette année
ça n'a jamais été aussi important en
toujours regarder le verre à moitié vide
moi je regarde le verre à moitié plein
en 2014 2015 il n'y aura jamais autant
d'installations de jeunes agriculteurs
donc c'est indispensable malgré tout
malgré la faible perspective de revenus
pour ces jeunes qui s'engagent dépend
dans quel secteur
oui aujourd'hui reconnaissant quand même
si le salon se passe plutôt pas mal
si le président de la république a
plutôt été bien accueillie c'est à mon
avis pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que les prix agricoles sans
pas aussi bas que cela les bus la
deuxième raison que j'aurais dû mettre
en premier c'est la négociation
européenne
le président de la république et
stéphane le foll ont réussi une
négociation européenne qui permet quand
même d'assurer à ce pays des retours de
l'europe
oui personne n'aurait pensé que ce soit
ce niveau la personne et même le
président le puissant président de la
fnsea a reconnu que c'était inespéré
alors c'est jamais assez les
négociations de la pac elle n'a pas plu
à tout le monde les céréaliers se
sentent floués dans cette histoire et
les cours des céréales sont en constante
baisse
non mais attendez là peut-être trop
avantagés lui s'est pressée de la
réorientation les aides européennes
80% des z aller à 20% de 20 % des
producteurs des exploitants nous voulons
réorienter ces aides c'est le cas dans
la prod la future pac 2014 à 2020 et je
peux vous dire notamment avec la
priorité sur l'élevage qui est
indispensable la priorité à l'élevage va
permettre de redistribuer les aides
européennes en direction des élevages
notamment des petits élevages
donc il faut regarder quand même
l'ensemble certains sont forcément pas
contents mais d'autres le seront mieux
ne se rend plus alors si on parle des
élevages justement vous êtes pour ou
contre le projet de ferme des
millevaches dans la somme non je ne suis
pas favorable je ne suis pas favorable
parce qu'on peut dire pour ou contre la
une ferme de millevaches
moi je sais pas expliquer d'un mot un ça
va l'idée de
de construire en france ce qu'on trouve
d'ailleurs en allemagne c'est à dire des
fermes gigantesque avec donc là c'est un
des seuls industriels qui achètent 1001
qui crée une faire alors il semblerait
qu'un excès un sens au lieu où le lait
devient un sous-produit de la
méthanisation
je pense que c'est pas ça le modèle de
la culture en france pour ça qu'il faut
pas dire on est pour ou contre les mille
vaches l'agriculture et les diverses
là il faut que l'on puisse faire de
l'élevage ovin il faut de l'élevage
caprin de l'élevage bovin il faut de
tout alors effectivement il faut aussi
être concurrentiel il faut travailler à
l'export et peut-être que de vendre du
du de la poudre de lait en chine
bah ça ça rapporte des hits des devises
et pour ça profite à beaucoup de gêneurs
normand et je suis et j'y suis favorable
à l'or c'est sûr et c'est ferme
gigantesque millevaches pourquoi vous
êtes content parce que sur les mille
vaches à trois personnes qui travaillent
comprenez et moi je préfère qu'il y ait
50 exploitations agricoles à l'intérieur
desquels y en ait deux ou trois qui me
travaille sans fera bon en plus la fnsea
dit on est dans une europe à 28 on peut
pas ignorer ce que font nos voisins en
allemagne en a plein des fermes 2000 de
millevaches
oui mais moi madame mon modèle ce n'est
pas l'allemagne
mon modèle c'est la ville encore ne
trouvait pas le chef de sida mais vous
savez en france il ya une exception
culturelle
et bien moi je pense qu'il pourrait y
avoir une exception agricole aussi parce
que l'histoire de la france quand même
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale en a
demandé aux agriculteurs français de
nourrir l'europe et ils l'ont bien fait
et de nourrir avec une culture intensive
productiviste et puis on s'est aperçus
qu aujourd'hui il fallait peut être
réorientés ça parce que les sols étaient
dans des situations dramatiques et c'est
la tournée l'argument attend c'est la
raison pour laquelle le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane le foll dans sa
loi d'avenir mais comme objectif
l'agroécologie alors justement
l'agroécologie parlons-en ça veut dire
que l'écologie est plus importante que
l'agriculture aujourd'hui mais non mais
vous avez une drôle de lecture si je
peux me permettre clair que je vais je
vais vous la définir tout à fait
clairement l'agroécologie c'est tout
simplement ne pas faire que du
productivisme et de l'intensif c'est
aussi prendre en compte la situation de
notre planète et la situation de nos de
nos terrains et il ne faut pas opposer
l'écologie et l'agriculture
moi je refuse cette opposition parce que
trop souvent lorsqu'on a mis l'écologie
en face de l'agriculture on s'est aperçu
que l'écologiste et des taxes
supplémentaires et vous savez nos
ordures ou d'agriculteurs gênante
hassaïm l ecologie jean reno bien sûr
mes horizons mais ils ont raison
ces dernières années beaucoup trop de
normes qui ont été mises en place et
rien n'a été fait pour les verts
diminués et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ça me dit le président de la
république au salon en ouverture du
salon a dit qu'il voulait réduire
l'énorme en agriculture comme dans le
pays il y en a beaucoup trop et en ces
années ont supprimé les agriculteurs ont
supprimé beaucoup et en réduire
certaines est contradictoire avec le
projet agro écologiques non non pas du
tout non pourquoi
bah parce que si on supprime les normes
comment on opposer l'écologie dans les
champs mais dans ma tête je crois que
vous n'avez pas c'est bien compris ce
qu'était l'agroécologie 6 permet la
prise et je vais essayer d'expliquer il
faut mettre le développement durable
s'appuie sur un trépied
c'est pareil pour l'agriculture le
développement économique le social et
l'environnement le développement
économique c'est le point numéro un qui
est dans cette loi c'est ce qui est
affirmé par le président de la
république lorsqu'il a rencontré les
dirigeants agricoles
c'est ce qui a été dit dans la loi le
développement économique l'économie la
compétitivité c'est indispensable
sans cela rien ne pourra se faire donc
ne me faites pas dire que c'est
l'écologie qui va tout faire le
développement économique
on peut on se dit peut-être en vous
écoutant que vous essayez de conjuguer
les extrêmes en tous les cas en tous les
cas des visions opposées en essais de
conjuguer une nouvelle hier en essais de
conjuguer une nouvelle pratique de
l'agriculture
force est de constater que ce qui s'est
passé ces 50 dernières années a été bon
dans le sens de l'aspect nourriture de
nos concitoyens mais n'a pas été très
bons termes environnement garder les
fermes de millevaches par exemple
certains disent c'est le meilleur moyen
justement pour contrôler la pollution
l'attendait là nous sommes aux sages et
culture est si on interrogé tous les
agriculteurs qui sont là y en a pas un
qui vous défendre elle affirme de big
match eux ce qu'ils vous disent c'est
que moi je
ne dis pas non mais y'a pas à dire non
pas non madame y'a pas dire non aux
panon s'ils veulent s'installer ils
auront le droit de le faire mais moi je
défends l'agriculture paysanne
moi je défends l'agriculture avec des
agriculteurs et les paysans qui sont là
qui sont sur le stand ddd des bovins ou
des ovins eux ce qu'ils veulent c'est
vendre leurs prix du lait et le vendent
plus que plus qu'aujourd'hui
ces vendeurs leurs agneaux qui ne soit
pas égorgé par des moutons et les
vendent le plus haut possible c'est ça
qu'il valait ce que vous rien sommes là
pour défendre six agriculteurs
c'est avec ces petites exploitations là
qu'on va s'en sortir c'est comme ça
qu'on va récupérer des places sur
l'échiquier mondial
non madame pour moi c'est avec les
exploitations d'aujourd'hui que nous
allons nous en sortir
la capa avec une hypothétique
exploitation de demain non mais c'est
pas ce que vous essayez de concilier
tout le monde là vous prenez pas
vraiment partie vous essayé mais
expliquez moi pourquoi je prendrais
partie répondre à une question qui n'est
pas une question de stratégie agricole
ce n'est pas une question mais la
question est que faire je pose la
question différemment données jaune dans
l'europe
nous sommes dans l'union européenne
et manifestement tout le monde tout le
monde n'est pas logé à la même enseigne
bien sûr c'est la région pour regretter
le manque d'harmonisation
évidemment que je le regrette c'est la
raison pour laquelle avec le pacte de
responsabilité avec les engagements qui
sont pris par le président de la
république et le premier ministre nous
arriverons harangue l'agriculteur
françaises plus compétitives notamment
au niveau des charges que nous ferons
aussi mais moi je préfère je préfère
qu'elle gardait toutes les exploitations
d'aujourd'hui avec des gens à
l'intérieur et des jeunes qui
s'installent les moderniser et les
rendre plus compétitives que de créer
dix ou quinze fermes à 1000 vaches et de
supprimer 50 ou 60 exploitations
agricoles pas là de la conséquence est
celle là c'est clair dernière question
peut-être sandra en rapport justement
avec la loi de modernisation agricole
dont didier yo mais le rapporteur
s'il ya beaucoup d'amendements quand
même un qui vont arriver au sénat alors
oui la droite vous reproche justement de
de renoncer à l'agriculture
productiviste dans cette dans cette loi
vous leur répondez quoi là qu'ils se
trompent d'ailleurs le débat a déjà eu
lieu au sénat en commission et j'ai pu
constater qu'il y avait eu aucun votre
contre en commission et que après
explications ils craignent ils craignent
lorsque certains lorsqu'on voit le mot
écologie que l'on parle de petits aux
autres petites fleurs et pas de
compétitivité et j'ai essayé de vous
dire que la volonté du président de la
république du premier ministre et du
ministre s'était justement de consigner
l'ensemble
alors on dit c'est inconciliables non ce
n'est pas inconciliable c'est sûrement
plus difficile mais on ne peut pas faire
aujourd'hui comme si de rien n'était on
ne peut faire aujourd'hui comme s'ils
avaient pas besoin de mettre un peu
d'environnement dans nos productions
on peut pas faire aujourd'hui comme si
on va pas continuer à mettre autant de
phytosanitaires dans les sols voyez
c'est ça l'esprit de compétitivité et
défense de l'environnement ont pris la
démarche je parlais des amendements y en
a sur le vin qui a retenu mon attention
oui enfin c'est pas vraiment
michel et c'est un projet de loi d'un
d'un sénateur ps qui propose de
distinguer le 20 juillet
voilà à fait d'accord avec lui je les
fais rentrer je les fais rentrer dans la
loi d'avenir imposition quoi ces deux
c'est tout simplement de dire que bien
sûr il faut lutter quand les cases
consommation abusive et qui verra mais
malheureusement enfin malheureusement
les jeunes qui se tuent reçoit une boîte
de nuit il a pas but du croate mitage de
l'ermitage du vin de bordeaux de
bourgogne et je pense qu'il faut arrêter
avec cette stigmatisation du vin le
projet qu'il y avait c'était ne plus
pouvoir faire de publicité sur internet
si on ne fait plus de publicité sur
internet
j'ai la moitié des caveaux des côtes du
rhône qui femmes comme en bourgogne sera
bordeaux mais bien sûr le bas c'est
aussi un sportif
non non non c'est la victoire de
l'économie madame voulait faire de
l'économie ben moi je vous donne un
exemple il ya ceux qui veulent tuer
l'économie viticole
moi je veux la profondeur augmente les
taxes sur la bière mais pas sur le vent
non mais ça n'a rien à voir on prélevait
ya beaucoup de taxes réserve anglaise à
quai comme cela si notre culture s'est
vautré dire merci sandra laffont pensée
de jeu une interview très offensive mais
cas très documenté merci beaucoup
perrine tarneaud arrive depuis le sénat
maintenant pour la troisième partie de
preuve par trois on va parler du sénat
de gauche mais qui ne votent pas tous
les textes de gauche en loin s'en faut
et on vous attend également la sur les
ogm avec une clarification nécessaire
ces derniers exemples effectivement
d'une rebuffade pour le gouvernement au
sénat mounir souci aucun ogm ne poussera
en france cette année à coup d'arrêtés
de moratoire le gouvernement utilise
tous les moyens juridiques pour
interdire leur culture et s'engage dans
un bras de fer avec l'union européenne
qui autorise le maïs transgénique sur le
continent mais si la france est hostile
à la génération actuelle de gm
elle pourrait se laisser tenter par la
seconde génération qui se profile avec
deux séduisants arguments sur le papier
demain il ya des eaux d'autres ogm
je prenais par exemple celle du riz doré
dans lequel on augmente la teneur en
vitamine a absolument nécessaire pour
lutter contre la cécité vrai débat qui
méritera d'être organisé le
ministre de l'agriculture entrouvre la
porte à ces ogm d'un nouveau type
un débat est prévu fin avril sous
l'autorité du haut conseil des
biotechnologies
le gouvernement espère qu'il débouchera
sur une évaluation sereine des avancées
scientifiques
je veux toujours raisonner en terme de
bénéfice risque c'est à dire on prend un
risque
effectivement en utilisant des plantes
comme ça mais pour en avoir un certain
bénéfice donc on espère que le bénéfice
qu'ils entrent n'en retirera sa
infiniment supérieur à un pari que les
écologistes refusent toujours de prendre
chez les verts le principe de précaution
l'emportent sur la recherche
le jour où on a fait tous les tests et
caetera et qu' on est on a trouvé
quelque chose qui peut être intéressant
pour le public on verra à ce moment là
mais aujourd'hui ce que se plier tenter
d'être expérimentée en plein champ c'est
des choses qui sont là qui n'ont aucune
utilité pour la collectivité et qui ne
servent que le business les tests
restent aujourd'hui cantonnées aux
laboratoires une contrainte qui ralentit
les scientifiques dans leur expérience
cette situation un peu de blocages qui
est politique qui nous dépasse mais nous
n'avons pas à juger mais c'est vrai
qu'elle pénalise une production de
connaissances scientifiques qui serait
pourtant bien utile au long terme des
données nécessaires car aujourd'hui près
de 80 % des français reste toujours
méfiant vis-à-vis des ogm
voilà perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint
bonsoir permission a dit guillaume sur
les ogm
sur le semestre elle a aussi un autre
organisme n'est pas génétiquement
modifiés bonsoir didier guillaume c'est
donc le sénat qui a mis le gouvernement
dans l'embarras
sur cette question des ogm en rejetant
la proposition de loi socialiste il ya
donc une majorité au sénat pour les ogm
je ne sais pas je pense que cette
proposition de loi n'a pas été assez
bien amener peut-être en vitesse elle le
débat a eu lieu
ça reviendra ça va passer à l'assemblée
ça reviendra au sénat
et je pense qu'il y aura peut-être un
autre vote au sénat à la prochaine à la
prochaine lecture c'est l'écrivain et
d'anticipation du gouvernement sur cette
question des ogm alors s'est posée qu'il
en ait manqué un petit peu en tout cas
qu'au sénat il est manqué deux idées
manqué d'anticipation savez le débat sur
les ogm ce débat de société et stéphane
le foll le ministe fait bien de lancer
ce débat dans la société
aujourd'hui il existe depuis plusieurs
années je ne l'a jamais été au bout n'a
jamais été mené aux roues aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire je suis pour ou contre les
ogm
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que le
monsanto 810 de pioneer tc 15 107 celui
ci il ne faut pas les accepter mais
demain la nouvelle itération du
moratoire où se trouverait au revoir et
j'y suis très favorable je soutiens le
gouvernement de toutes mes forces mais
par contre demain si on trouve une
deuxième génération 2g m la regardant
d'ailleurs dans la nourriture que nous
mangeons venus de l'extérieur
nous mangeons aussi des ogm vous savez
en quantité minime pour l'instant
irlande mais pour l'instant il fit
consommateurs je pense qu'il faut
objectiver le principe de précaution et
savoir ce qu'il en est réellement nos
que nos concitoyens les consommateurs
veulent de la transparence et ne veulent
pas des ogm
donc voilà il ya un débat sur la table
si demain nous trouvions une nouvelle
génération de gm qui permettent de par
exemple faire pousser du maïs dans
l'afrique sub saharienne sans beaucoup
d'eau est ce qu'on dirait non il ne le
faut pas regardons tout cela c'est ce
que dit stéphane le foll dans le sujet
et françois hollande qui est venu sur
votre stand vous l'avez dit michel tout
à l'heure samedi pour l'inauguration du
salon vous le confirmer il a réaffirmé
sa volonté d'avancer sur ces ogm de
seconde générale
oui il l'a réaffirmé je pense qu'il a
raison autant sur le moratoire
aujourd'hui il ne faut pas bouger
d'ailleurs le président de la fnsea a
dit hier aujourd'hui qu'il n'y aurait
pas de plantation de ces ogm la de ces
maïs ogm l'a donc ya pas de sujet par
contre il faut avoir un vrai débat sur
la deuxième génération et voir ce qui
peut être fait et la voir sereinement
l'encore centre de cure anti scab sur
les gaz de schiste pas d'obscurs en
pareille pas d'obscurs le sujet oui vous
avez entendu denis baupin dans le sujet
il les verts ils sont pas tout à fait
favorable à ces ogm de seconde
génération et garanties supplémentaires
mais aujourd'hui on ne peut pas réaliser
cette question c'est la raison pour
laquelle le ministre et le gouvernement
souhaite mettre ce débat sur la table
avec des scientifiques et nous dire est
ce qu'elle est garantie ou est-ce qu'il
y en a pas on va parler du sénat un
petit peu maintenant
didier guillaume est ce qu'on septembre
2014 donc au prochain renouvellement
sénatorial vous espérez qui aura une
majorité plus claire de gauche comme de
droite
je crois qu'il y aura une majorité de
gauche au sénat en septembre 2014
c'est bon c'est mon intime conviction
oui je suis assez confiant on va
attendre évidemment le résultat des
élections municipales
mais le sénat c'est une élection un peu
différente de toutes les autres elle ne
répond pas aux sondages traditionnels il
ya des temps des municipales il ya les
départements il sort la bonne pour le
gouvernement allemand qui sont
renouvelables et gauche qui ne sont pas
renouvelables
je ne sais pas si elles seront pas
bonnes pour le gouvernement on verra il
y aura un revers après on en connaît pas
l'amplitude mais a priori nous nous
regarderons ça nous étudierons ce recul
quand même ces municipales au pire un
revers comme le dit michel nouader
quelques voix d'avancé au sénat sa
rentrée dans la technique ça dépend dans
quel département
on me perdre beaucoup de que deux villes
dans un département qui n'est pas
renouvelables et ne pas en perdre
d'instruction renouvelables donc pour le
sénat il faut regarder la moitié des
départements renouvelables pour se faire
une opinion
elle a juste sur les municipales pour
poursuivre jean françois copé qui
appelle à dire stop à françois hollande
à l'occasion de ces élections
municipales vous craignez ce vote
sanction
je ne le crains pas mais je trouve cela
désolant
je trouve cela désolant de prendre en
otage les électeurs d'une élection
municipale en leur disant j'ai raté mon
coup la fois d'avant nous avons perdu en
j'ai raté mon coup parce que j'ai pas
vraiment été du présent
mp donc je vais me faire une virginité
en disant mais c'est moi le patron en
tapant avec mes petits bras sur la table
je suis le patron de la droite donc
écoutez moi donner une sanction au
président de la république lors de ces
municipales je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que cela et que les les
électeurs ne répondent pas aux
injonctions de monsieur kobe et qu'ils
voteront en fonction de ce qui se passe
dans leur commune mais nous verrons bien
c'est dans un mois
il exprime est généralement leur un sens
c'est un satyre extrait ainsi
satisfaction par dont celle qu aux
municipales aux européennes qui suivent
c'est un peu le lot intermédiaire c'est
vrai qu'un règle générale la majorité en
place
il ne gagne pas forcément les élections
intermédiaires pour revenir aux
sénatoriales de 2014 puisque c'est la
troisième étape de ces élections en 2014
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que ce
soit surtout le redécoupage des cantons
qui pourrait valoir finalement à la
gauche sénatoriale ces quelques sièges
d'avancé non je vécu quand même d'aller
département sur un découpage je ne crois
pas ça dépend où il sait pas très bien
vécu parce qu'on change beaucoup de
change beaucoup de choses vous savez la
gueule grand changement dans cette
élection cantonale
c'est que la prochaine fois en 2015 il y
aura autant de femmes que d'hommes et
moi j'entends les arguments des hommes
qui disent vous fait hara-kiri vous
supprimez mon canton ils sont tannés moi
je suis très content très content qu'il
y autant de femmes que d'hommes et que
dans les départements qui est la parité
c'est un premier argument
il faut le prendre en compte et ceux qui
rencontrent ils iront expliqué qu'il ne
souhaite pas que les femmes rentrent et
c'est la deuxième sujet c'est quand même
une réalité aujourd'hui moi je si je
vous prends le cas de mon département
il ya des cantons à 31000 trente deux
mille habitants et d'autres à 900
habitants et il faut rééquilibrer et
puis quand même le fond de cette affaire
c'est que nicolas sarkozy avait voulu
réformer en créant le conseiller
territorial perdu le sénat en 2011
c'est constitutionnel indique qu'il faut
la parité et l'équité devant l'élection
donc nous verrons bien nous
argumenteront vous savez tout al'air
michel grossiord me disait jean françois
copé veut supprimer les départements ils
auront quand même beaucoup de mal à les
expliquer que c'est pas bien d'avoir
fait des cantons paritaire alors qu'ils
veulent supprimer les départements
nous aurons un vrai débat
et il faut des régions plus fortes aussi
un c'est ce que lui le projet de
décentralisation
un projet de loi du gouvernement alors
votre département ces parties de la
région rhône-alpes il faut l'agrandir
encore cette région en allégeant
notamment n'ont peut-être un peu sur
l'auvergne c'est la première région hors
région capitale déjà donc c'est une très
grande région moi je pense plusieurs
choses d'abord il faut des plus grosses
régions entre huit et douze régions ça
irait très bien où 14 peu importe le
chiffre il faut qu'elle soit réduite
plus fortes à l'échelle européenne en
mordant sur l'eau vers nous sur provence
alpes côte d'azur peu importe il faut
des grandes régions
mais pourquoi ne pourrions nous pas dans
notre pays considéré que notre france
est diverse dans qu'elle ne peut pas
être géré de la même façon ici ou là il
ya eu un référendum en alsace si ce
référendum avait marché
ça aurait été une nouvelle gestion
différente d'ailleurs ce qui passe à
lier ce qui se passe à lyon avec le
visionnaire qu'est gérard collomb et et
michel mercier
bah ça va être différent d'ailleurs je
trouve ça très bien moi je trouve ça
vraiment bien il faut chaud il faut tout
changer dans notre pays on est sur des
bases du siècle dernier
il faut préparer le siècle suivant là
pour parer le ciel est attendu qu'ils le
font parce que souvent il ya du camp je
ratisse machado que j'ai à faire du
corporatisme parce que je trouve cela
ridicule
nous ne sommes nous sommes de passage
nous les élus nous ne sommes pas là pour
défendre un pré carré défendre une
indemnité défendre un poste ça n'a
aucune importance ce qui doit nous
intéresser
c'est que les hommes et les femmes les
enfants demain commence la gestion sera
faite au niveau national comme au niveau
local c'est ça l'enjeu et il faut bouger
moi j'aspire à ce qu'il est les
départements puissent se regrouper de
façon volontaire c'est indispensable moi
je travaille le département de l'ardèche
déjà depuis des années et nous
délibérons ensemble donc les endroits où
cette avancée avançons il n'y a pas d'
il ne peut pas y avoir de limites la
seule limite qu'il y a c'est une chose
les collectivités locales aujourd'hui
font de l'investissement cet
investissement permet aux entreprises de
se maintenir ou créer de l'emploi
et attention à ne pas trop leur coupé
les cordons de la bourse
nous devons faire un effort nous
acceptons de le faire mais
l'investissement dans ce pays il est
fait par les collectivités locales
retour sur le sénat a dit guillaume
puisque vous êtes vice président du
sénat il y ait eu dans libération hier
une tribune publiée par le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat monsieur jean louis carrère contre
le sénat bashing est-ce que c'était au
président la commission des affaires
étrangères de prendre publiquement comme
ça la défense du sénat c'était à celui
qui souhaitait le faire jean louis
carrère a souhaité faire cet article je
pense que c'est bien je pense gris qui
se livre aujourd'hui au sénat bashing
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui pensent
que le sénat devrait fonctionner
différemment notamment certains
gouvernements notamment certains au
gouvernement qui pense que c'est plus
compliqué d'aller au sénat mais c'est ça
le débat parlementaire
c'est un peu plus compliqué au sénat une
majorité sénatoriale mais pas de
majorité gouvernementale
et puis aussi certains à droite qui
n'ont toujours pas digéré que le sénat
et il ya une alternance et qui veulent
rabaisser tirer le sénat vers le vers le
bas rien ne nous fera changer notre
position
le président du sénat est clair dans ses
orientations
il a quand même réussi à transformer
cette institution à la moderniser à
mettre de la transparence on préfère
réaliser la même chose d'appris dont il
a pris des positions assez assez forte
et bien il faut continuer dans cette
dans cette direction mais son
prédécesseur gérard larcher mais aussi
jean-pierre raffarin ils le disent qu'il
ne défend pas assez la maison senna
non il trouve qu'il ne défend pas assez
des positions de l'ump mais je pense que
non mais c'est moche que moi je vous
réponds ce qui ne défend pas assez stx
et c'est ce que ça veut dire
lorsque lorsque jean pierre bel défend
le sénat il défend un céda moderne dans
un bicamérisme rénové vous savez il ya
beaucoup de gens qui voudraient que le
sénat ne se s'occupe que des
collectivités territoriales que le sénat
soit une sous assemblée nationale ce
n'est pas ma conception ce n'est pas la
conception du président du sénat en
france les élus les députés sont élus
par le peuple et les sénateurs par les
représentants de la loi sur le cumul des
mandats va affaiblir le sénat la loi sur
le cumul des mandats va peut être
renforcée de senna je ne crois pas que
je crois pas qu'elles qu'elles
affaiblissent y aura des parlementaires
qui auront encore plus de temps à se
consacrer
et puis alors on peut dire oui c'est
vrai vous êtes vous président de conseil
général et sénateur
vous connaissez le terrain enfin on est
proche et les choses
quoi on n'est pas obligé d'être
président du conseil général pour
connaître le pour connaître le terrain
je souhaite je vais vous répondre
j'ai moi juste que je souhaite c'est
quelque chose de très simple c'est que
le sénat ait la même possibilité que
l'assemblée nationale de délibérer sur
les questions de société comme sur les
budgets c'est très important d'autres
choix personnel en 2010 cette demande
perrine je resterai au sénat vaut rien
si je suis réélu je ferai une
transmission comme je les fait dans ma
mairie
ad je passerai le flambeau à quelqu'un
dans mon département
voilà ça c'est dit vous nous avez dit
tout à l'heure que vous ne réclamez pas
de remaniement gouvernemental d'aidé
guillaume et si demain françois hollande
vous dit tu es prêt pour être ministre
d'agriculture
je ne vois pas pourquoi ils me poserait
cette question c'est bien l'agriculture
je suis sûrement pas le seul salut on
est en l2 salon si tous les rapporteurs
d'une loi art un jeune ministre au
gouvernement il y aurait 250 personnes
serait compliqué pour se mettre autour
de la table
le porteur de la loi sur l'agriculture
c'est vous et si stéphane le foll demain
et bien et parachutés sur le parti
socialiste pour prendre la place
d'harlem désir là il y aura une place là
vous êtes partis dans des élucubrations
journalistique que je peux comprendre
on n'en est pas là je pense que le
président de la république il est pas à
jouer aux dominos le président la
république qu'il a une orientation
claire bon en agriculture dans notre
sujet il avance il vous en ai pas touché
un mot samedi matin tout quoi de vous
battre en panne aura pas d'accord à bien
merci merci d'être ici
merci à tous bon soir et a très vite
bonsoir